I always find that you have to be a bit
mad to become a stone cover I mean this
isn't the Renaissance anymore stone is
in a primary building material anymore
why why would you go into an industry
why would you go into a profession that
is expensive and takes a lot of time and
the material is heavy and hard to move
and it is expensive to obtain even
before you do anything to it and then
after that even after you've made
something out of it you have to convince
people that this is a worthwhile
endeavor what I always find that the
answer to that question is always that
there just wasn't any other any other
option once the idea of becoming a stone
carver comes into your head then you
just have to find some way of doing it
every every project will usually start
with a sketch of some kind and if you're
lucky enough to have a live model then
it will start with a clay model so if
it's a head you'll find all them
prominences the sort of absolute
promises you'll find the tips of the
years you find the nose you'll find the
chin you'll find where the under hang of
the jaw comes down you'll find where the
sternal notch comes in you find the top
of the head you'll find sort of the
slope to the nose and usually the slope
to the chin and all the sort of angles
that make up a human face a sort of
geometric head if you will the clay when
you do a clay model of someone that's
where you're working out
the idea and you're getting acquainted
with their face and you're talking to
them and looking at them that's really
what it's about is just looking a lot of
people don't recognize the fact that
clay is quite it's an easy substance
it's soft its you can move it around
very fast you can build it up really
fast and then take it away really fast
and so there is no point in being
Precious about it if you make a mistake
you shouldn't you can just discard that
and start again and it won't take that
long if you can imagine doing something
if you have the skills to do it you can
pretty much execute anything that you
want and that that transition from your
imagination
through your eyes and your hands into a
block of stone is the most incredible
feeling stone carvers are often taught
that simply carving something in stone
is enough that that sheer ability to
take something that's been cut from the
earth and create something beautiful
with it is enough and that isn't
something that is shared by any other
kind of artist
[Music]
once you start once you start carving
this there is there's no sort of hard
and fast rules you rely on the fact that
you can look and to measure and that you
have an instinct for this and that if
you can look at something and translate
it into your hands and then make the
chisel to do what you want it to do then
you'll be okay if you're doing the clay
or if you're doing the transition from
the clay into the stone often my brain
is quite not chaotic but you're making
so many decisions probably until the
sort of last day that you're working on
it your brain is just constantly making
decisions of like am I have I taken that
too low like what am i doing like what
measurement is that like where's this
everything is just sort of going through
your mind very very fast and you're not
even aware that it's happening but then
you finish the day and you're exhausted
and you wonder why the sound that it
makes is incredibly satisfying a lot of
people who aren't Carver's comment on
that and that feeling of a like well
sharpen chisel going into stone smoothly
and cleanly and that transition of
looking at a stone and telling your
hands to do something and then your
hands telling a chisel and a mallet to
do something and then have it take off
exactly the right amount of stone have
it do exactly what you want to do is the
most satisfying feeling
on a human face even though there's a
change in pigment there's no and like
you come to the edge of the lips and it
just carries on going and if you try and
make it a stark difference then the face
will look strange the skin is sort of a
continuous surface that undulates
and has tension in certain places and
slack in other places
it takes a long time to train to be a
stone carver and it's not an easy job
once you are trained and you're still
learning I'm still learning with every
job that I do I learned something new
and I will hopefully continue to learn
and that seems to be the payoff that
once you've created something it has it
takes up a physical space in the world
and it it has a permanence that will
hopefully outlast you and it's not
vulnerable either
[Music]
I want people to see that I've pushed
the material as far as it can possibly
go I maybe want people to see themselves
in it
I want them maybe to wonder about my
reasons for carving it I want people to
have I want people to maybe argue about
why I made it in the way that I did and
have different ideas of what the reason
is and the purpose
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]